en quoi le 3 juin ne fais pas tu es ma
grand mère et oui mais c'était un petit
que c'est pour mon cancer est un cancer
bien mais je te paierai n'y a pas de
problème dès que j'ai réussi à arnaquer
tamer écoute tout nous sommes tous les
lieux parce qu'ils font tous ont su bien
armé du n'existe par as tu le sais maman
on t'a pas demander ton avis on est tout
seul dans la vie ça il faut retenir et
personne ne te fera cadeau tu peux me
passer un peu d'argent c'est bétonné
aussi que tu viens de nous voir sans
raison
tu me fait beaucoup de peine après tous
les efforts que j'ai fait pour changer
sur la tête des assedic
non je passais république league
il